you dare enter this house
you're crossing a cell line my friend
it's Thursday [ __ ] I've been a
little under the [ __ ] weather but I'm
back [ __ ] so get the pipes get
the ammunition we're going deep into the
murky waters on a [ __ ] Thursday
you
ah that's how opening this [ __ ]
how you guys doing I missed you
I'm still feeling a little touchy cool
side today but who gives a [ __ ]
everything gets healed with a little bit
of reefer love and hospitality you bad
[ __ ] uncle Joey here thank you
for listening to the 400 we were gonna
have a bunch of [ __ ] things but hey
it was just me and Lee taking it back
old-school the way it is all the [ __ ]
time I'm happy you guys are here I got a
big a big a big a big a big big a big
[ __ ] day today I got a lot of [ __ ]
going on but I got 10 minutes of my
[ __ ] family oh [ __ ] who's smoking
this [ __ ] said [ __ ] cookies Thin
Mint cookies from perennial good googly
moogly and I still got this [ __ ]
Skywalker that was killing us last night
this [ __ ] is too much [ __ ] I
need help i need help i can't smoke all
this weight by myself and you guys are
all over the [ __ ] cut you don't visit
you don't [ __ ] help everybody wants
to send we can't stay [ __ ] these post
office they got the [ __ ] eye of are
you [ __ ] crazy
it's a beautiful day the birds chapter
the sun's Apple Diary is a couple of
layers I'm not bombing three nights ago
I was over this [ __ ] mountain me
eating heaving pieces kidneys or pubic
hairs the whole [ __ ] deal but that
shit's over now got something want the
bigger better things like the Skywalk
it's time to set the earth man free set
him free set him free I gotta go
[ __ ] yeah you gotta go [ __ ] with
the numbers I'm giving it yeah you gotta
look at this batch of [ __ ] brief the
nice and dry and grill this [ __ ] and a
bomb was maybe but igniting you think
niacin take niacin and see what happens
to his skin is gonna get this tingling
when you have diabetes is [ __ ] take
niacin that's what happened last last
night this weeds got niacin in it
because our our weed started [ __ ]
arms started burning
we started sweating you dramatic listen
you know me I love marijuana but it's
gotta be [ __ ] good my tower and just
do the [ __ ] roof I ain't got time to
be smug I grew this nice I don't give a
[ __ ] where you grew a [ __ ] ain't
what I'm smoking
oh yeah oh yeah
feels nice to smoke and get all that
[ __ ] [ __ ] that was told to you
last night that book listen both those
conventions bullsh got nothing to do
with you you still gotta go to work you
still got a snap [ __ ] you still
gotta fight for your way hey it's a
bunch of [ __ ] even my wife was the
king of the Gentiles turn it off last
night nothing but [ __ ] [ __ ] you
know what never never never lies to you
come in reefer do we think that reefer
never lies to you it goes into your mind
honest the thoughts that come to your
mind are honest you can't didn't have a
face to [ __ ] wafer
every time those [ __ ] people talk
smoked reefer and then [ __ ] the
setting rates of the [ __ ] head
you gotta fight the powers I'm saying
fear of a black [ __ ] planet but they
don't do what he had them even those
black people at the [ __ ] convention
yesterday were all we Todd [ __ ] black
me they weren't cool black people I like
uh [ __ ] I grew up with these
parity [ __ ] them hearted [ __ ] young
strong [ __ ] heat they would show up
dead man [ __ ] people what are you
gonna do it's Thursday it's been a good
week you're alive you're making it
[ __ ] happen you understand me that's
the most important thing you're making
this up which with the reef the Joey
spark this soldier the [ __ ] I'm gonna be
a talking with an empty [ __ ] bowl
kind of host device I'm saying who shows
up with an empty [ __ ] phone
very nice
I'm sorry
it's nice when we get together after a
few days it smoked the [ __ ] boat my
family because who does this [ __ ] I
don't even want to hear the word fans
that's for [ __ ] these people think
they've done something
I got a fancy a family
it's even better you understand me we
breathe for one another this is what
it's all about Leon what a boxer Cleo
[ __ ] hope he's spooky I have said I
could drop oopy-scoopy out of a
helicopter with a [ __ ] knife and a
bikini on her she'll come back and
somebody's [ __ ] scalping understand we
got family bro this is [ __ ] stronger
than [ __ ] this reefer [ __ ] me up I'm
havin showtunes no [ __ ] people
you don't nice see you see this is
Thursdays about now you go out your head
is clear your heart beats a little
slower you got a little bit more focused
you got some oxygen you know exactly
what the [ __ ] you gonna do you an awful
Joey you can't go wrong
you don't saying I don't believe and
take the [ __ ] innocent people down
[ __ ] dark alleys every dark alley I
went that I went that alone without here
[ __ ] off so that's how we do it the
rest is up to you concept you got the
world by the balls I don't care if you
smoke and open whether this don't belong
to you nobody ever kidnap somebody
because they were smokin reefer kicked
my smoke too many balls that made me
think we know done
although this [ __ ] [ __ ] you up trust me
I was look at his face
as a part of that shafy is this [ __ ]
this is God's working [ __ ] Momo's
reef is God's work if you don't see that
go [ __ ] yourself all these people walk
around I'm a Christian this thing grows
out of the [ __ ] floor like all
consumptive and it worked magic powers
I don't know about habits crap listen
all I know is I smoked grief and I don't
kill nobody
and I feel good and I'm happy and you're
happy that's it that's the best
description that we could ever give me
besides that I think it's time to smoke
a little ball I'll see the [ __ ]
doubles malarial catchy of beatings from
white people whenever you have it oh got
an amp beating from white people you
gotta get a high so while they're
talking about the statistics and their
[ __ ] [ __ ] and their
self-importance you just thinking about
Jimi Hendrix playing the stock that's
the star-spangled banner or something
like that
they show up with their [ __ ] pencil
to my pad they tell you about their [ __ ]
of him at the end of the day they don't
know dick but for some reason we the
bottom level the blue column on the
[ __ ] like myself we get intimidated
haven't been to me in 30 years they love
suck my dick
while they were [ __ ] reading a book I
was out there [ __ ] mug and
[ __ ] for much money
robbing Jewish boys whatever
the fickle [ __ ] yourself I pack my own
lunch [ __ ] there's all these
[ __ ] but the [ __ ] we talking
about
am i [ __ ] right now I love this [ __ ]
leaving the house but I got a [ __ ]
zombie State these people watch The
Walking Dead I am the [ __ ] Walking
Dead [ __ ] you smoked two bowls of
this new Walker one see what that
mistake
all right besides that I got [ __ ] to do
and people to [ __ ] see
[Music]
I'm stole to the [ __ ] gills the way
he's supposed to leave the house and
left hands already forbidden seven Terry
had some twenty [ __ ] things already
we got back to made a few calls and sent
some emails now maybe I will do what I
gotta do I gotta figure out how to get
exercise and today I'm busy I'm
top-heavy in the [ __ ] morning so
maybe if I could do some kettlebells
later at the Sun or something like that
get a little vitamin B that's it I'm
gonna put some CBD oil on my phone tie
nail today I'm gonna start that
experiment if this [ __ ] CBD or worse
on my thumbnail we got a problem
not to call the government talk to
that's it that's that
I'll show you that your own [ __ ]
dilemmas but that's it
I love you [ __ ] stay black have a
good day keep the eyes open I'm saying
they pull that piece pour yours do not
[ __ ] hesitate don't hesitate don't
[ __ ] stutter don't do nothing shoot
back get him in the leg and run then
Dahlia Darcy so whatever the [ __ ] you
wanna do you wanna go home
it's a beautiful day to be alive don't
let nobody [ __ ] stop yet the another
day they can all suck it dick [ __ ] them
you're gonna get to the point of your
destination uncle Joey
I'll see you [ __ ] tonight we'll
smoke a bowl before I go to the food
trucks next week Oklahoma at the
Cherokee nation's casino I'm [ __ ]
excited to see the [ __ ] Indians you
don't me I'm down with the Indians that
we can't feel happened Denver at the
Comedy Works and then at the end of the
month I'm doing the [ __ ] hot
war Thor I'm doing a no expectation
floor that's my [ __ ] hour with no
material just be talking stupidity and
you people looking at morning Joe what
the [ __ ] did we come here for anyway
I Love You God something and stay black
have a great dental and nobody [ __ ] with
you